explain to them  okay so the first we're protesting or  the vaccine mandate and the vaccine  passport so what is the vaccine passport  that means anytime you come into canada  you're going to have to have this app  downloaded into your phone  and it will uh track the status of your  kovid shot so if you need more shots and  you don't get them  then you you you don't pass you have to  go back to the united states as a  trucker and you have to get a pcr test  and wait whatever the period of time is  and then come back but the other thing  is this affects you guys as well  because the biden administration is  implementing the same thing right  however we know from our friends within  politics and in journalism apparently  the biden administration even the biden  administration had zero interest in this  but the trudeau government apparently  lobbied the biden administration and  convinced them to adopt a similar pro